welcome to this video playing kill 88
from yeah this is one of those United
Arab Emirates Kuwait united arab
emirates okay i'm trying to get a fatty
door let's see something okay is going
for this sad boring queen train line but
playing quickly I don't know it that
well I hope is not busting me with some
with some sharp theoretical line that I
don't know yeah I he could have played
Bishop c4 already which looks which
would have been a slight problem okay
okay yeah well here this is this a cell
interesting it should be second also
take maybe taking us the way to go
trying to play actively now of course
every move gets played immediately such
an easy position okay i'm brookie eight
should be 4i don't know it's not easy at
all this is position I think but maybe
that just mean trip III here
yeah maybe
ok so now i can i can take take F for
this is a bit not very very rewarding
maybe Rokan it attacking you form ok or
just take you ok I can give this check
now and then take onee tool but keep
also just just retreat
keep this IDM in the position it's not
so easy for y to make a move here
cannot castle up the same due to the
bishop only three yeah I can grab a pawn
now maybe I can I should do that just to
to make it a bit simpler to Plame check
let's got H FOIA right did I run and
right into this it's not so easy now h4b
should be too i don't have any great
squares okay yeah this wasn't just bad
this stuff like okay this is easier to
play and just leads to leads to leads to
problems der it typical well okay how do
i play that
Knight to e5 would be would be brilliant
but not sure how to get it down
neither maybe can go nigh g7 er
attending I don't know ninety seven
hours as possible not really my t5
that's not easy to play this stuff
rookie 7 was very annoying but should be
a tonight a 4 would be nice to get in
check
now I could have played 97 actually now
I could have done it and this would
probably just wind it wanted night only
five is so strong American where do I go
with a key I'm are gonna be here I
simply didn't see that the look was
saying great great know what a game
it's not taught not clear I mean this
position is not clear but of course it
should have been been over while ago
check Dobson I take the Rope white
resigns yeah I think actually here I'm
in good shape because of the apron now
Black is winning here yeah but it wasn't
his was total total mess around here i
mean i should just win the game without
any any [ __ ] but i didn't i didn't
manage it was simply a totally totally
bad idea to grab this pawn for all the
giving up all the positional advantages
for this bloody pawn I should just go
back and this is a disaster why Cannot
Castle I just play 97-95 route d8 I mean
this is just such a great piece and it's
not a child easier to play here because
i have a bad piece coordination this was
bad ha ha
oh yeah and this is not clear no I mean
ESS night on a 5 the active King
everything in play I'm really oops I'm
really glad to not having lost it here
just a moment okay baby i need to attend
the dome yeah this is just very tricky
to play the civil stuff done 97 now I
was thinking about the compass giving it
as equal but I couldn't really work out
if this is check how this has to be
assessed I saw this line but i thought
this also could be tricky because he
would probably win one poem back here
and he has got the more active King with
this I was I wasn't sure computers has
equal okay I went here check my deaf was
good according to the engine I was
thinking that this was very strong
actually I but just minus 0.6 so not
like winning or anything
no Jack five check now camp-wide should
draw this easily whoo yeah very
complicated stuff and here i'm on i'm
better again but i simply i simply
blundered this in one move I didn't see
that the rook was attacked as simply
didn't simply didn't I just wanted to
get out of the beef I'll rock t4 seems
to be a quite clearly winning for black
according to the engine I but I just
blundered this and just blend it like
this and now white is ok but yeah check
he made some some bends i think a four
is really a bad decision it helps me
check in term oh this is even stronger
check check this is this is just a total
is this is a simple promotion we're like
it's just running check running the pawn
to a 190 okay blonde at the rook but it
was already a very problematic as you
see here here check he should avoid the
capture and then a porn is just
promoting him okay thanks for watching